حسام الجدل القانوني والقضائي وحتى
تنظيميه حول المسار المتعلق بالانتخابات
التشريعيه القادمه هيئه الانتخابات تعلن
عن قبول 1055 ملفه ترشح لهذه الانتخابات
بناء على قرار المحكمه الاداريه المشرفون
على هيئه الانتخابات يقولون ان قرار
المحكمه يؤكد سلامه قراراتها رغم التشكيك
ومحاوله ضرب المسار الانتخابيه
مش غريبه
من قبل تنصيب هذا المجلس انطلقت في اطار
استفتاء ثم
انتخابات تشريعيه الحمله هدفها سياسي معلن
ومكشوف هو درب مسار الانتخابات محاوله
اربيكا ومحاوله افشالها ومحاوله اجيلها
ومع بدايه العد التنازلي لاجراء
الاستحقاقه التشريعيه يؤكد المشرفون على
هيئه الانتخابات جاهزيتها بوصفها الجهه
المناظمه للعمليه الانتخابيه بينما تختلف
الاراء وحد التضارب بين المعنيين
في الشان الانتخابيه حول القوانين
المعتمده وشروط الترشح وطبيعه الحمله
الانتخابيه ورغم سلامتي الاجراءات
القانونيه عملت هيئه الانتخابات على تبسيط
بعض المسائل الغامضه المتعلقه بضبط قواعد
تمويل دعايه وطبيعتها والغاء التمويل
العمومي وتمويل الاحزاب ومرشحيها مقابل
السماح بالتمويل الذاتيه مسائل تباينت
حولها اراء المترشحين والمنظمات
في جوابات
القانون لانه التبسيط مش على الاقل الناس
تفهم راحه وتعرف انت ايش تعمل
25 نتصور انا حتى
هناك لكن كثيره جدا من المترشحين كانت بعض
التساؤلات اللي هي وبعض الغموض حول
التمويل كل المترشح داخل الانتخابات
محافظه الروحه مع القانون مش معقول بعد
التزكيات وبعد مرحله تزكيات خاطريه اهم
مرحله نجيب سنعود ونرجع نحكي على التامين
العمومي اللي يتنحقق وفي وقت رفضت محكمه
القضيه التي رفعها الحزب الدستوري الحر
لابطال الانتخابات تقضي الرزنامه بانطلاق
الحمله الانتخابيه بعد اربعه ايام الى
غايه السادس عشر من ديسمبر المقبل قبل يوم
من التوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع في الداخل
وليد عبد الله العربيه تونس